Y la forma en que eso ocurre nos habla realmente de los propios planetas.
Porque si pensamos en el sistema solar,
podríamos pensar en esta imagen.
Y diríamos, bueno, hay ocho planetas, quizá nueve.
Para quienes estén estresados por esta imagen,
añadiré algo para Uds.
(Risas)
Cortesía de Nuevos Horizontes, incluimos a Plutón.
Y esto de aquí,
a fines de esta charla y de la fuga atmosférica,
Plutón es un planeta en mi mente,
al igual que los planetas que orbitan otras estrellas que no podemos ver
también son planetas.
Una de las características fundamentales de los planetas
es que son cuerpos
unidos por la gravedad.
Mucho material unido
por esta fuerza que atrae.
Y estos cuerpos son muy grandes y tienen mucha gravedad.
Por eso son redondos.
Por eso al mirarlos,
incluso Plutón,
son redondos.
Se puede ver que la gravedad realmente entra en juego aquí.
Pero otra característica de los planetas
que aquí no se ve,
es su estrella, el sol,
alrededor del cual orbitan todos los planetas del sistema solar.
Y eso fundamentalmente guía la fuga atmosférica.
Las estrellas fundamentalmente guían la fuga atmosférica de los planetas
porque ofrecen a los planetas partículas, luz y calor
y eso puede hacer que las atmósferas se fuguen.
Si piensan en un globo de aire caliente,
o miran esta foto de las linternas en Tailandia en un festival,
ven que el aire caliente puede impulsar los gases hacia arriba.
Y con suficiente energía y calor,
algo que el sol produce,
ese gas, que es tan liviano, solo retenido por la gravedad,
puede escapar al espacio.
Eso es lo que provoca la fuga atmosférica
aquí en la Tierra y en otros planetas.
Esa interacción entre el calor de la estrella
y el poder de superar la fuerza de gravedad del planeta.
Ya les conté que ocurre
a una tasa de 180 kilos por minuto de hidrógeno
y unos 3 kilos de helio.
Pero ¿qué pinta tiene eso?
Bueno, ya en los años 80,
tomamos imágenes de la Tierra
en ultravioleta
con la nave espacial Dynamic Explorer de la NASA.
Estas dos imágenes de la Tierra
muestran el aspecto del resplandor de la fuga de hidrógeno,
en rojo.
Y también pueden ver oxígeno y nitrógeno
en ese resplandor blanco
en el círculo que muestra las auroras
y también algunos mechones alrededor de los trópicos.
Son fotos que nos muestran de manera concluyente
que la atmósfera no está estrechamente unida a nosotros aquí en la Tierra
sino que, en realidad, se propaga hacia el espacio,
a un ritmo alarmante, podría añadir.
Pero la Tierra no está sola en la fuga atmosférica.
Marte, nuestro vecino más cercano, es mucho más pequeño que la Tierra,
por lo que tiene mucho menos gravedad con la que mantener su atmósfera.
Y, aunque Marte tiene una atmósfera,
podemos ver que es mucho más delgada que la terrestre.
Solo vean la superficie.
Se ven cráteres que indican que no tuvo una atmósfera
que pudiera detener esos impactos.
Además, vemos que es el "planeta rojo",
y la fuga atmosférica juega un papel
en que Marte sea rojo.
Por eso pensamos que Marte solía tener un pasado más húmedo,
y que el agua tuvo suficiente energía y se descompuso en hidrógeno y oxígeno
y el hidrógeno, al ser tan liviano, escapó al espacio
y el oxígeno que quedó
oxidó el suelo,
generando el rojo familiar oxidado que vemos.
Está bien mirar imágenes de Marte
y decir que quizá ocurrió la fuga atmosférica.
Pero la NASA tiene una sonda actualmente en Marte llamada satélite MAVEN,
y su tarea real es estudiar la fuga atmosférica.
Es Atmósfera Marciana y la nave Evolución Volátil.
Y sus resultados ya han mostrado imágenes muy similares
a lo visto aquí en la Tierra.
Hace tiempo que sabemos que Marte estaba perdiendo su atmósfera,
pero tenemos algunas imágenes impresionantes.
Aquí, por ejemplo, pueden ver el círculo rojo
del tamaño de Marte,
y en azul se puede ver el hidrógeno que se fuga del planeta.
Está llegando a más de 10 veces el tamaño del planeta,
suficientemente lejos como para ya no estar vinculado a ese planeta.
Se está fugando al espacio.
Y esto nos ayuda a confirmar ideas,
como por qué Marte es rojo a partir de ese hidrógeno perdido.
Pero el hidrógeno no es el único gas perdido.
Mencioné helio en la Tierra y algo de oxígeno y nitrógeno,
y con MAVEN también podemos mirar el oxígeno que se pierde en Marte.
Y pueden ver que dado que el oxígeno es más pesado,
no puede llegar tan lejos como el hidrógeno,
pero aun así se fuga del planeta.
No se lo ve todo confinado a ese círculo rojo.
Por eso ver no solo la fuga atmosférica en nuestro propio planeta
sino poder estudiarla en otros sitios y enviar naves
nos permite aprender sobre el pasado de los planetas
pero también sobre planetas en general
y sobre el futuro de la Tierra.
Así que una manera de aprender sobre el futuro
es mediante planetas distantes que no podemos ver.
Y debería tener en cuenta, sin embargo, antes de continuar con eso,
no les voy a mostrar fotos como esta de Plutón,
que podrían ser decepcionantes,
porque no las tenemos aún.
La misión Nuevos Horizontes está estudiando la fuga atmosférica
que ocurrió en Plutón.
Estén atentos y esperen.
Yo quería hablar de los planetas
conocidos como exoplanetas en tránsito.
Cualquier planeta que orbita una estrella que no sea el sol
se denomina exoplaneta, o planeta extrasolar.
Y estos planetas que llamamos en tránsito
tienen la característica especial
de que si uno mira esa estrella del medio,
verá que en realidad está parpadeando.
Y la razón del parpadeo
es que hay planetas que pasan por delante todo el tiempo,
y está en una orientación especial
en la que los planetas bloquean la luz de la estrella
y eso nos permite ver el parpadeo.
Y examinando en las estrellas en el cielo nocturno
este movimiento parpadeante,
podemos encontrar planetas.
Así hemos podido detectar más de 5000 planetas
en nuestra propia Vía Láctea,
y sabemos que hay muchos más por ahí, como he mencionado.
Así que cuando miramos la luz de estas estrellas,
no vemos, como dije, al planeta en sí,
sino un oscurecimiento de la luz
que podemos registrar en el tiempo.
Así la luz decae conforme el planeta pasa delante de la estrella,
y ese es el parpadeo que vimos antes.
Así que no solo detectamos los planetas
Pero podemos mirar esta luz en diferentes longitudes de onda.
Mencioné observar la Tierra y Marte con luz ultravioleta.
Si observamos exoplanetas en tránsito con el Telescopio Espacial Hubble,
encontramos que en el ultravioleta,
se ve un parpadeo mucho más grande, mucho menos luz de la estrella,
cuando el planeta pasa por delante.
Y pensamos que se debe a una atmósfera extendida de hidrógeno
alrededor del planeta
que le da un aspecto más hinchado
bloqueando de ese modo más luz de la que vemos.
Mediante esta técnica hemos podido descubrir en realidad
algunos exoplanetas en tránsito que sufren fuga atmosférica.
Y estos planetas pueden denominarse Júpiteres calientes,
a partir de algunos que hemos encontrado.
Y eso debido a que son planetas de gas como Júpiter,
pero están muy cerca de su estrella,
unas cien veces más cerca que Júpiter.
Y como está todo ese gas liviano listo para escapar,
y todo ese calor de la estrella,
existe una tasa catastrófica de fuga atmosférica.
En vez de los 180 kilos por minuto de hidrógeno que pierde la Tierra,
en estos planetas
se pierden unos 590 millones de kg de hidrógeno por minuto.
Puede que se pregunten, bueno, ¿esto hace que desaparezca el planeta?
Y eso se pregunta la gente
al mirar nuestro sistema solar,
porque los planetas más cercanos al sol son rocosos,
y los planetas más lejanos son más grandes y más gaseosos.
¿Podría haberse comenzado con algo como Júpiter
que estuviera cercano al sol,
y perdiera todo su gas?
Ahora sabemos que si uno empieza con algo como un Júpiter caliente,
no puede terminar en Mercurio o la Tierra.
Pero si uno empieza con algo más pequeño,
es posible que se fugara suficiente gas
como para producir un impacto significativo
y dejara algo muy diferente al planeta con el que empezó.
Todo esto parece algo genérico,
y podríamos pensar en el sistema solar,
¿pero qué tiene que ver eso con la Tierra?
Bueno, en el futuro lejano,
el sol va a ser más brillante.
Y conforme eso ocurra,
el calor recibido del sol será muy intenso.
Del mismo modo que el gas que se fuga de un Júpiter caliente,
el gas saldrá de la Tierra.
Y podemos esperar,
o al menos prepararnos,
para que en el futuro lejano,
la Tierra se parezca más a Marte.
Nuestro hidrógeno, del agua que se descompone,
se fugará al espacio más rápidamente,
y nos quedaremos con este planeta seco y rojizo.
No teman, no ocurrirá hasta dentro de miles de millones de años,
así que hay tiempo para prepararse.
(Risas)
Pero quería que estuvieran al tanto de lo que ocurrirá
no solo en el futuro,
sino que la fuga atmosférica ocurre mientras hablamos.
Hay mucha ciencia asombrosa que uno oye que ocurre en el espacio
y planetas muy distantes,
y estudiamos estos planetas para aprender sobre estos mundos.
Pero conforme aprendemos sobre Marte o exoplanetas como Júpiteres calientes,
encontramos cosas como fugas atmosféricas
que nos dicen mucho más sobre nuestro planeta Tierra.
Tengan en cuenta eso la próxima vez que piensen que el espacio es lejano.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)